foreign
must be very obvious
this is an extraordinary judgment
delivered in an extraordinary way
in which the commission is clearly
deeply troubled
by the case it's having to decide and by
the limitations based on it by the
Supreme Court
they
implication the outcome
that we face is that no British child
who has been trafficked outside the UK
will be protected
by the British state if the Home
Secretary votes National Security
you would like to say a number of things
Daniel but we have a number of
collective things to remind you of
the judgment
I think what what really jumps out of
the judgment is what the commission
didn't say what they didn't do is
endorse what Sajid Javan said in
September 2021 he said you haven't seen
what I saw if you did know what I knew
your sensible responsible people you
would have made exactly the same
decision of that I have no doubt
in fact this commission which saw
exactly the same material because I just
saw didn't say anything like that at all
he described the case as finely balanced
and said that reasonable people might
strongly and profoundly disagree with
what the way in which is being
determined
so I do you want to say something more
about trafficking
credible suspicion
there's traffic a credible suspicion
that she was harbored by the traffickers
until 2019 a credible suspicion that
there are extraordinary failures
within the UK in preventing her failing
to prevent her and her friends traveling
reading the factual underpinning of what
commission considers to be made out on
this Bacon's law you would feel that
there will be no way that she could not
have succeeded in her appeal but you
will equally see repeated as a threat
through the Judgment how a commission
invokes the Supreme Court's view that
its role was limited and it cannot
consider the merits of a case it's
limited to the most narrow grounds of
administrative review
in consequence you have a judgment in
which the court is effectively saying as
things stands now we are stuck in a way
that we do not think reflects the
findings we are making
so uh that's basically is I mean in
terms of people fight that's that's
nowhere near over we're not going to go
into details about exactly what that
means at the stage I think what what
else this judgment calls out for though
is um some some courage and some
leadership from the Home Secretary to
look at this case of fresh in light of
the clear and compelling factual
findings that this court has made thank
you but you will appeal we're going to
challenge the decision but we're not
going to go into further there's no no
limit to the challenges that you know of
you they include
the government
taking on responsibility of conducting
its own review
what Prospectors
you've known before they've known she
will have known as you've broadcasted
and so we'll be speaking speaking to
those we can speak to immediately now
he wasn't allowed to know the outcome
until 10 am today and neither was
thank you very much
cool
oh yeah thank you